[Music]
a question I get quite often is what is
sea steady and seasteading started out I
guess in 2008 it's it's a movement it
started out as as a nonprofit so it's
called the seasteading Institute based
in California but I think just a couple
months ago it ceased Endings actually a
word that's recognized by the oxford
dictionary and what it means is living
on platforms at on the open oceans and
with new forms of society so the way I
got involved in sea steadiness I was a
government minister in French Polynesia
so a lot of people know my country by
the name of Tahiti and when I left the
government I was looking at interesting
opportunities for what we could do in
especially in terms of sea level rise
mitigation is a it's an issue that's
quite front of mind for a lot of Pacific
Islanders especially now and I had come
across this this Institute write about
them they were very there's a lot of
media focus on them back in 2008 2010 12
so basically I reached out to to the
Institute and said my understanding was
that they had built a huge network of
specialists of aqua preneur of
scientists researchers investors but
what the movement was was missing was
the support strong support of a
government the that was willing to have
a light hand on on regulation and allow
such an ambitious project as as the
first the world's first sustainable
self-sustaining floating island so
French Polynesia had the advantage when
when I reached out to to see studying to
have several things that the Institute
was interested in and one of the first
questions they asked was about
connectivity so you know is your country
connected to the Internet backbone
connectivity is obviously crucial for a
big data that's going to be generated by
the researchers a scientist so the first
thing was do you have a submarine cable
and so we check that one off
2010 french polynesia connected to
Hawaii so we're right on the Internet
backbone huge unused capacity
I think 99% unused so obviously
available for for research and the
second major concern was about
hurricanes cyclones and tsunamis so
basically all right we're gonna be doing
this this pilot project floating island
obviously the weather and the situation
in your country is important to us so we
did some research I already know from
from being from French Polynesia that
this was a very rare occurrence I think
we've had two hurricanes you know the
last hundred years that had significant
damage there was property damage a very
light loss of life and tsunamis are not
really an issue for us we're in the
middle of the South Pacific so we get at
least an eight-hour window before any
tsunami were to hit us but just given
the geomorphology of the islands we
don't get these high waves that you get
when you have a continental shelf the
objective of the pilot is to get all of
these technologies tested on a smaller
scale it's small yet we should be able
to support around 200 people so our
objective is 200 to 250 people living
full-time there would be about a third
research and scientists a third will be
people who just love to live on sea
Stead's and we've got a long list of
people who want to come live on honesty
stead another third we believe are going
to be startups and entrepreneurs that
are building technologies around the
ocean so basically all sort of blue tech
you've got underwater drones you've got
all of these different types of startups
that are linked to to the space we also
have the issue of energy now obviously
we we need internet on board the these
platforms we will have some low energy
lighting low energy pumps and we're
gonna be very careful with everything
that goes on board this these structures
but we feel fairly confident that there
are enough ways for us to to generate
energy so we're looking primarily at
floating solar panels there's a company
we're in discussions with in France it's
got some
in technology it's not just as simple as
putting solar panels on the water it's
you know it's the corrosion resistance
it's a wave you know how you mitigate
for wave action but here's the
interesting part about solar panels on
the water as opposed to solar panels on
land the water actually cools the solar
panels the back of the solar panels and
it increases the yield by about 20% so
we've got some advantages to that so
we're doing calculations as to exactly
what surface area we would need we're
going to be using some solar panels of
course on some of our roofs but in
addition to that we're looking at
there's some pretty modern wave wave
generation techniques so we're inside
the reef but there are waves right
outside of the reef so these are units
that actually are underwater I think
about eight to ten twelve feet
underwater so they they won't disrupt
normal commercial you know boats going
out there leisure or commercial there's
not these are underwater they just
basically our buoys it's fairly complex
a nail they just take in that wave
energy is a little bit less but there's
still quite a bit of wave energy and
that will create addition to just a
solar so on our pilot project we we have
an idea of what we're doing for power
but ultimately the objective of these
platforms is to go to the open sea the
research has been done now I think it's
a matter of funding and of focusing all
of this on one major project and that's
our objective is first let's do this
this pilot let's prove that these
technologies work together let's prove
that people can live in on these
platforms in a in a new social way and
that's that's something that Polynesians
are very interested in as well I mean we
were the original sea stutters in the
sense that we've you know colonized and
migrated throughout the Pacific for a
thousand years and covered you know one
of the largest oceans in the world so
living on the ocean is something that
Polynesians know about and I think we
have a lot to contribute to the project
as well
[Music]